neue stufe der gewalt in den usa nach
dem tod eines afroamerikaners wächst die
wut der demonstranten
die nationalgarde ist im einsatz zurück
im all nach neun jahren pause hat eine
amerikanische raumkapsel an der
internationalen raumstation iss
angedockt
pfingsten im zeichen der korona pandemie
die kirchen fordern solidarität und
fürchten wirtschaftliche probleme wegen
geringerer steuereinnahmen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster herzlich willkommen bei
den nachrichten am pfingstsonntag und
auch heute wieder zu erster blick in die
usa wo sich die proteste gegen rassismus
und polizei gewalt weiter ausbreiten
pikant brief ich kann nicht atmen
zitieren demonstranten die letzten worte
des afro amerikaners george floyd kurz
vor seinem tod nach einem brutalen
polizeieinsatz
die empörung darüber ist in den letzten
tagen zu einer landesweiten bälle
angewachsen und schlägt oft ihrerseits
in gewalt um
mindestens 25 städte in 16 bundesstaaten
verhängten ausgangssperre die aber immer
wieder gebrochen werden vielerorts gibt
es plünderungen und vandalismus in san
francisco und los angeles wurde die
nationalgarde angefordert
aus den usa ines trams sämtliche
soldaten der nationalgarde waren in
minneapolis aufmarschiert so viele wie
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg nicht eine
ausgangssperre war verhängt worden doch
beachtet wurde die nicht wut über
rassismus im alltag der usa spricht sich
erneut waren
ich will in einer weise gegen gehen
können und mich sicher fühlen wenn ein
polizeiwagen hinter mir fährt will ich
keine angst haben ich will einfach frei
sein
proteste im gesamten land polizei gegen
demonstranten gebäude und polizeiautos
werden angezündet wut entlädt sich in
pure gewalt hat geht die polizei vor mit
gummigeschossen und tränengas in new
york wird ein einsatzwagen in die menge
statt zu deeskalieren setzt präsident
frank weiter auf eine harte gangart die
new yorker polizei lobt er
lasst new yorks beste die besten sein es
gibt niemand feineren aber ihnen muss
erlaubt sein ihren job zu machen
geschäfte und supermärkte werden
geplündert ungezügelte gewalt der
demonstranten oder nutzen extrem linke
oder rechte gruppen die situation unklar
hilflose versuche die proteste in
ruhigere bahnen zu lenken
ich bitte euch mit eurer energie nicht
unsere nachbarschaft zu zerstören
zerstört damit die historisch gewachsene
kultur des systemischen rassismus
streu am morgen nach einer erneuten
nacht von gewalt viele städte liegen in
trümmern
es muss einen echten wandel geben ich
verstehe die empörung aber die meisten
die das hier gemacht haben sind nicht
verlassen
eine pandemie hat das land im griff eine
soziale krise die der folgt nun die
politische krise amerika steht vor
unruhigen zeiten
unruhige zeiten für war fragen an
unseren amerika korrespondenten l
materie sind zuerst noch mal nach dem
präsidenten elmar man hat wirklich den
eindruck er heizt die empörung noch mit
anstatt die lage zu beruhigen warum tut
er das ja das fragen sich auch manche
seiner anhänger sie würden sich sogar
wünschen dass er vor die nation tritt
eine rede an das land hält so wie es
einst anfang der neunzigerjahre george
bush senior getan hat damals war in los
angeles ein mann namens rodney king
totgeprügelt worden von der polizei
danach gab es krawalle und dann hat
george bush senior damals gesagt dass es
höchste zeit sei das klima zu verändern
eine ablehnung zu schaffen gegen jede
art von rassismus und antisemitismus und
jede art von hass das hat damals ein
bisschen zur beruhigung beigetragen das
erhoffen sich hier viele aber und das
ist das problem durch seine tweets durch
seine äußerungen hat der öl ins feuer
gegossen heute morgen auch wieder indem
er ankündigt die antifa möglicherweise
zur terror-organisation zu erklären also
manche sagen vielleicht ist es ganz gut
wenn er sich nicht an die nation wendet
weil er es vielleicht noch schlimmer
machen würde und wie soll amerika dann
als diese situation politisch wieder
herausfinden
das ist äußerst schwierig wir befinden
uns ja im wahlkampf im november wird
gewählt das heißt auf der einen seite
wichtig und richtig dass beide parteien
sich überlegen mit welchen konzepten sie
die großen probleme angehen das sind
natürlich einerseits die pandemie zum
zweiten die wirtschaftskrise über 40
millionen arbeitslosen zum dritten dann
eben diese gewalt die sich hier bahn
gebrochen hat eigentlich auf beiden
seiten
und insofern kommt es auf konzepte an
die sind allerdings nicht in sicht und
es besteht die gefahr dass in den
nächsten monaten was all diese fragen an
hier eher stillstand herrscht weil man
sich im wahlkampf gegenseitig angreifen
will
vielen dank für ihre einschätzung elmar
theveßen in washington die usa in
aufruhr wie das land versucht die
protestwelle in den griff zu bekommen
und wo weitere ausgangssperren gelten
das und mehr können sie nachlesen online
in der zdf- heute- app noch eine
entscheidung in washington präsident
trump will den ursprünglich für juni
geplanten g 7 gipfel in den herbst
verschieben
außerdem stellte das g7 format an sich
in frage
die bisherige zusammensetzung der länder
sei völlig veraltet er wolle deshalb
auch russland südkorea australien und
indien einladen
es ist ein neustart der bei vielen
hoffnungen weckt der flug von zwei
us-astronauten in der crew dragon zur
raumstation iss für den us-präsidenten
nichts weniger als die rückkehr zu den
sternen
künftig sollen die bemannten raumschiffe
des tesla erfinders allen masc
regelmäßig abheben
mit seiner firma spacex hat er schon ein
neues ziel ins visier genommen den mars
david sauer
millimeterarbeit in 400 kilometern höhe
der moment als die dragon kapsel vor gut
zwei stunden an der iss andockt zwei
astronauten haben den außenposten der
menschheit erreicht fast einen tag nach
dem start
robert banken und des höhe sind die
helden mit sicherheitsabstand herzen sie
nochmal ihre familien bevor sie in der
spitze der rakete platz nehmen
als unter ihnen 26 millionen ps zünden
beginnt dann das abenteuer space ex
bringt als erstes privatunternehmen
astronauten ins weltall
das hat uns hoffnung gegeben für die
ganze nation die gerade mit so vielen
dingen zu kämpfen hat und jetzt guck dir
das an neun jahre waren amerikaner nur
gast in russischen sojus kapseln das war
sehr teuer
auch deshalb hat der staat milliarden in
spacex investiert ein teil der rakete
ist wieder verwendbar sichere landung
auf einer schwimmenden plattform im meer
wir sind wieder da diese nachricht kann
der präsident gerade gut gebrauchen
heute erneuern wir unser engagement für
die zukunft amerikas im weltall und wir
sollten uns auch für eine bessere
zukunft für alle hier auf der erde
einsetzen
besonderen applaus für spacex gründer
elon musk im august schon will die nasa
mit seinen raketen die nächste crew zur
iss schicken
in brasilien nimmt die zahl der
ansteckungen mit dem corona virus weiter
rasant zu innerhalb eines tages
registrierten die behörden mehr als
33.000 neue fälle ein trauriger rekord
weil brasilien nicht flächendeckend
testet gehen experten davon aus dass
noch deutlich mehr menschen erkrankt
sein könnten
die zahl der todesopfer ist auf über
28.000 800 gestiegen und die entwicklung
in deutschland zeigt die zahl der korona
neuinfektion ist im vergleich zum vortag
konstant geblieben im durchschnitt der
vergangenen sieben tage steckten sich
täglich 460 menschen mit dem corona
virus an christen in deutschland haben
wieder pfingst gottesdienste in den
kirchen feiern können unter strengen
hygiene auflagen
der ratsvorsitzende der evangelischen
kirche bedford strohm sagte in der krise
sei die globale zusammenarbeit wichtiger
als je zuvor
bischof bätzing der vorsitzende der
katholischen bischofskonferenz
befürchtet dass corona krisenhafte
phänomene in der kirche beschleunigen
könnte die kirchen leiden auch
finanziell unter den corona folgen
steuereinnahmen brechen weg marion
geiger
das pfingstfest sehr reduziert im
mainzer dom nur 50 gläubige auf lücke
platziert corona schadet der seelsorge
und den kirchen finanzen denn mit der
konjunktur bricht die kirchensteuer ein
die haupteinnahmequelle der kirchen im
bistum mainz macht sie 70 prozent der
gesamteinnahmen aus
wir rechnen aus kirchensteuereinnahmen
20 prozent weniger durch corona das
bedeutet rund 45 bis 50 millionen euro
weniger kirchensteuereinnahmen 2020 den
kirchen entstehen weitere verluste durch
leerstehende tagungshäuser und abgesagte
veranstaltungen mieteinnahmen fehlen
sowie elternbeiträge für kitas und
schulen
das bistum mainz war zuvor schon
defizitär und hat nun eine
haushaltssperre verhängt es gilt alle
ausgaben neu zu prüfen wird gerne mehr
aufbauen als abreißen aber wir müssen
uns natürlich auch der realität stellen
und vielleicht sind schwerpunktsetzung
auch inhaltliche schwerpunktsetzung auch
noch mal eine chance sich zu fragen
welche botschaft denn als kirche wir
haben in dieser gesellschaft und was
wird wofür wir eigentlich stehen und die
korona krise verschärft dass
zukunftsproblem der katholischen und
evangelischen kirche in deutschland sie
verlieren mitglieder die einnahmen
sinken doch sparen fällt schweren
kirchen ausgaben sind zu 70 prozent
personalausgaben und zu 20 prozent
bauausgaben das heißt da ist nicht viel
luft und das sind alles quasi fixkosten
so stehen beiden christlichen kirchen
schmerzhafte einschnitte bevor
noch schneller als vor corona gedacht in
der fußball bundesliga wurde heute
bereits gespielt borussia
mönchengladbach gewann zu hause deutlich
gegen union berlin mit 4 zu 1 und das
wetter am morgigen feiertag wird nach
ein paar dichteren wolken im südosten
später überall sonnig die
höchsttemperatur liegt zwischen 20 und
28 grad auf den ostseeinseln bei 18 grad
und bis mittwoch bleibt es so freundlich
dann kommen von westen schauer und
gewitter auf
das war es von uns schön dass sie dabei
waren ein heute journal gibt es heute
auch zur gewohnten zeit um 21 uhr 45 mit
claus kleber und hier geht es weiter mit
berlin direkt ich wünsche ihnen noch
schön pfingstmontag bis morgen